Salut tout le monde, Lundi je vous ai demandé sur Facebook et sur Twitter
ce que vous vouliez que je vous raconte aujourd'hui.
En ce jeudi, le fameux jeudi de "jeudi-ce que je veux"
Mais je dis surtout ce que vous voulez.
Pour ça j'ai mis un petit sondage sur Twitter, j'ai d'ailleurs fait une connerie dans le sondage puisque
je l'ai laissé valide que 24h au lieu de le laisser valide 4 jours
Bon, c'est la première fois que je faisais, j'ai découvert
Mais en 24h vous avez eu le temps de répondre, vous avez répondu nombreux, merci !
Et vous m'avez réclamé une True Story, une histoire vraie
Un petit peu comme la fois où j'avais raconté comment j'avais retrouvé mon Mac
J'avais perdu un Mac dans un train et j'ai réussi à le retrouver
Je vous raconte d'ailleurs l'histoire ici !
Alors aujourd'hui je vais vous raconter comment je suis rentré, sans payer, à Disneyland Paris
C'est pas une histoire très longue, mais c'est une histoire vraie
Ca s'est passé en 2011, déjà il faut savoir qu'en 2011 j'avais un pass annuel pour aller à Disney
On m'avait offert un pass annuel pour mon anniversaire et je pouvais rentrer à Disney quand je voulais
Je devais rejoindre quelqu'un à Disney, c'est à dire que je pars de chez moi pour aller à pied jusqu'au métro
je prends le métro pour aller jusqu'au RER, je prends le RER pour aller jusqu'à Disneyland
et j'arrive à Disney.
Je me dirige vers la grande entrée qu'il y a, la très grande entrée
pour aller passer mon badge dans le tourniquet
et je m'aperçois que... j'ai pas mon badge...
Et là, c'est assez inconfortable parce que j'ai pas mon badge, il y a des gens qui m'attendent dans le parc
Ce qui est sûr et certain c'est que je vais pas faire l'aller-retour jusqu'à chez moi
pour aller chercher le badge, et je n'ai pas non plus de quoi me payer un billet d'entrée
puisque...autour du badge j'avais rangé mon portefeuille...
En clair, je suis parti les poches vides
Là je me suis dit : "C'est impossible de rentrer à Disney sans payer, mais bon va falloir quand même tenter un coup"
Au niveau de la grande entrée, là où il y a toutes, toutes, toutes, toutes, toutes les caisses, c'est l'entrée principale
Je me suis dit "Ici c'est mort, je pourrais rien négocier même si je vais à l'espèce d'accueil qu'il y a à cet endroit là"
Jamais ils voudront me parler
Donc j'ai cherché une autre entrée, je suis allé, quand on est face à Disney, sur la droite
Là où il y a je crois la bagagerie
Oui, voilà, c'était au niveau de la bagagerie
Et c'est vrai que de ce côté là, le matin, il n'y avait personne
Je m'approche de l'accueil de la bagagerie, qui est aussi un accueil secondaire de l'entrée de Disney
Et j'explique en fait que je n'ai pas ma carte,  que je n'ai pas mon pass, mais j'espère qu'avec mon nom
ils vont pouvoir me retrouver même si, je vous le rappelle, je ne peux pas justifier mon identité puisque
je n'ai pas de portefeuille...
Alors là c'était assez drôle, c'est une jeune fille qui m'explique qu'elle peut rien faire en fait
Que même avec le nom, même si j'avais ma carte d'identité de toute manière elle ne pourrait pas me faire rentrer
si il n'y a pas de pass, la règle est stricte. Personne ne rentre sans son pass ou sans un billet
A partir de ce moment là, je me suis dit "Je vais toujours acquiescer"
Je ne vais jamais être dans le négatif, jamais être déçu, mais je vais être dans l'attente
Je m'explique, je dis "Ah, ok ok, je comprends tout à fait, est-ce que du coup je peux voir un responsable ?"
Elle hésite, je répète ma phrase, je change pas un mot
Je fais "Non mais vraiment je comprends, mais est-ce que je peux voir quand même un responsable ?"
Son responsable arrive sur la petite porte, une vraie porte physique qu'il y a sur le côté
Et dès qu'il a ouvert la porte, j'ai fait la technique du commercial
Je suis rentré direct, pour pas qu'il puisse surtout pas refermer
Et j'avançais un petit peu, sans rentrer dans ce qu'on appelle sa "bulle d'intimité"
Mais je m'avançais pour qu'il recule un petit peu pour rentrer vraiment dans le couloir.
Je lui explique toute la problématique, que j'ai un pass, que je l'ai oublié chez moi
J'étais souriant, en gardant la même ligne de conduite, toujours dire "oui"
mais attendre
C'est à dire que je lui explique le problème, il me fait "Oui mais nous, sans pass,
on ne peut pas vous faire rentrer" je fais "Ok, d'accord, ça j'ai compris
et c'est très très embêtant, du coup on fait comment ?"
Et j'attends. En passant peut être un peu pour un blaireau quand j'y repense
Le mec me réexplique "Même avec votre nom, dans le fichier, même si on pouvait vous retrouver
on ne pourrait pas vous faire rentrer,
on n'a aucun moyen, même physiquement, quand bien même on le voudrait de vous faire entrer"
Je fais "Ha ok, oui oui d'accord, je comprends, et c'est embêtant, du coup on fait comment ?"
Et à chaque fin de phrase, je répétais le "on fait comment ?", sans agressivité
toujours avec calme, et surtout en lui barrant le passage, c'est à dire que si lui voulait passer,
ou que je me pousse, il était obligé de monter d'un ton dans la conversation
alors que jusqu'à maintenant j'avais été le mec le plus sympathique du monde
Juste, je lui barrais la route, il ne pouvait plus sortir, et il ne pouvait plus faire demi-tour
parce que je bloquais aussi l'accès au bureau et je le laissais répéter ces phrases
en disant "Oui je comprends, mais du coup on fait comment ?"
Je pense de mémoire que ça a bien duré 5-6 minutes
Ca parait pas long quand on dit 5-6 minutes, mais c'est assez long à vivre dans ce genre de situations
Jusqu'au moment magique, ça me fait rire en fait d'y repenser,
Jusqu'au moment magique où il me fait "Bon, écoutez, je vais vous faire rentrer,
par contre vous ne pourrez pas sortir ou re-rentrer comme vous voulez
et c'est la première et dernière fois que ça arrivera"
Donc là on passait du "c'est impossible quand bien même on le voudrait" à
"je vais vous faire rentrer"
Autant vous dire qu'à ce moment là, je suis resté très modeste, très humble,
pas fait exploser ma joie parce que là ça contrecarrait tout ce que j'avais fait au préalable
En gardant vraiment la même base d'intonation, la même base d'énergie alors que
j'avais envie de faire "OOOOOOOUUUIII, C'EST BOOON"
Il avait une carte blanche, il m'a fait rentrer avec cette espèce de carte blanche
Je suis rentré dans le parc, j'ai profité du parc toute la journée
Je suis donc rentré dans Disney sans billet, sans rien du tout
sans invitation, sans que dalle ! Je suis rentré dans le parc 1, le grand parc
Alors, après je me dis que c'était pas du vol puisque j'avais le pass annuel chez moi, quoi
sauf que je ne l'avais pas avec moi...
Evidemment, je vous déconseille d'éviter de faire la même chose
Faut pas qu'il y ai 2 000 personnes demain à Disney qui tentent ça
Je suis même pas sûr que ça pourrait se reproduire
Moi j'étais en stress permanent durant toute cette histoire
C'est à dire que je savais quelle technique utiliser pour accéder à ça,
mais j'avais un vrai doute sur le fait qu'il ai vraiment le pouvoir de me faire entrer ou pas
Et j'avais qu'une crainte, c'était qu'il appelle la sécurité en fait, comme je bloquais le passage
Mais c'était assez drôle de tenter le coup. Je regrette à l'époque ne pas avoir eu de caméra en 2011
pour filmer ça, ça aurait été assez marrant je pense en cam cache
Merci d'avoir écouté cette True Story, j'espère que ça vous aura plu
Vous pouvez d'ailleurs me le dire en laissant un petit pouce en l'air
ou un comm' en bas, je les lis tous
En ce moment je suis un peu à la bourre pour répondre mais je vais rattraper ce retard, ça c'est promis
Lundi prochain je vous solliciterais encore, de nouveau, alors je sais pas encore
Sur Twitter, sur Facebook ou sur Instagram, en tout cas je relayerais l'info sur les trois réseaux
Hésitez pas, à chaque fois c'est "Fabien Olicard"
Et vous déciderez encore de quelque chose pour la vidéo de jeudi
N'oubliez pas avant de partir de vous abonner à la chaîne parce que
le Mental Vlog c'est une vidéo par jour, tous les jours, pendant un an
Alors rendez-vous demain à 17h pour le prochain Mental Vlog, Ciao !